اهلا من جديد والان معنا نشره اخبار ال
المصري اليوميه واللي صارت فقره اساسيه
عندنا خلاص على الاقل حتى اشعار اخر
واليوم ماسك اختبار او انتباهي يكون هو
عنوان لسلسله او هو اختار انه التباه يكون
عنوان للسلسله تغريدات القرار استعرض فيها
انجازاته في تويتر في الكم اسبوع اللي
فاته فنشر صوره لرسم بياني وعلق عليه انه
يظهر
1.600 مليون
مستخدمين انه يعني موضوع المستخدمين الجدد
واستقطابهم هو من اكبر تحديات من الصوت
الكبير وخصوصا تويتر اللي معروف انه هذه
من اكبر ازماته انه ما بيجذب مستخدمين جدد
فهو علشان كده بيتبعها بهذا الموضوع ومن
امس ومزاج الى الماسك مايل للتنكيت والضحك
والسخريه تغريدات وقلتنا ولناها امس وكان
بينكد فيها وما ترك احد من شره اليوم ما
لقي احد ينكد عليه فنكد على نفسه وقال وسط
تغريدات كثيره انه لحظه يا جماعه داحين
لمن انا بغرد كده هل يعتبر هذا انه انا
جالس بشتغل يعني هو بصراحه يعني الجماعه
لازم يعطو له راتب اضافي على الساعات اللي
شرس بيقضيها ماسك يعني صراحه على تويتر هو
جالس بيغرد وبيرد على
المتابعين يعني ولا اقول لكم اصلا راتب
ايش ما هو اصلا بيملك الشركه كلها يعني
معلش معلش
خلينا نروح لعنوان ثاني من عناوين نشره
اخبار الماسك هو خبر الدفعه جديده من
المطرودين وحسب موقع دجاج فعلا طرد ماسك
دفعه جديده هو موظفي شركه الان صاروا 2700
موظف بعد ما كانوا 7,500 قبل ما يشتري
ماسك لكن مع هذه الاخبار في الاخبار عن
اجتماع لمسك مع الموظفين اعلن لهم في انه
خلاص الطرد خلص اما في اي طرد جديد وعشان
يكون واقعين مشاهدينا وسط كل اللي جالس
بيصير ماسك عامل انقسام بين الناس ناس
كثير جلسه بتنتقدوا وناس وهذول الناس
تحديدا شايفين انه هو جالس بيدمر منصه
تويتر وبيعمل قررت جنونيا ولكن كمان في
ناس بتحبوا وشايفه انه لا يا جماعه هذا
الرجل عن جد وجهها نظره يعني عنده وجهه
نظر خلينا نقول عنده رؤيه مستقبليه
ومعجبين في صراحه لاقصى الحدود في تفاعلكم
احنا متابعين مسلسل ماسك معكم طبعا اليوم
بيوم من اول لحظه
ومراسل العربيه حسين الطن موجود في سن
فرنسيسكو امام مقر تويتر وكمان بيغطي
القصه لحظه بلحظه هناك امس بناس من هذول
اللي حابين الماسك ثم مثلا وسط كل
الاقالات اللي جالسه بتصير والاحتجاجات
التقى بشخص قاتل نفسه على وظيفه في
التويتر
السيسي
[موسيقى]
اثنين
اللي شفتوه هذا لابس الماسك خوفا قال انه
خايف لو تعين في تويتر والناس عرفت انه
بيحب ماسك فيقوم ويقلبوا عليهم عموما غير
هذا مراسلنا كمان التقى بيوتيوب لو اكثر
من شهر امام المبنى املا في حضن بس من مصر
جهاز